-We're talking about cascading
system-wide effects, Ian.
-Gosh, that's a drag.
-What is the matter with you?
-Drag?
-Why? Is there something special
you wanted me to do?
-How about give a damn?
-Far too much not to care.
-Hey. I gave my opinion robustly
for years.
As expected,
the sum of our human endeavors
has led to our annihilation.
And the only play now is to take
the time that we have left
and, uh, you know, just like
we always do, squander it.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
That was a clip from
"Jurassic World: Dominion."
We're here with Jeff Goldblum.
And your friends.
-Well, yes, yes. How about that?
Don't they look great?
The great Sam Neill
and the great Oscar-winning
Laura Dern, of course.
-You have all --
All three of you
have aged fantastically well.
-I don't know about me.
They have.
They look like supermodels.
-And this is the first time
you guys have worked together,
all three of you, since 1993.
-Not been reunited on screen or
anyplace else professionally,
you know, all this time.
I adore them, you know,
and they've changed my life.
They're so wonderful.
But what was I gonna say?
Wait a minute.
-The three of you together...
-Oh, the three of us together!
Yes, yes, and we're not --
We're not -- That isn't
all of us in the movie.
-Yeah.
-We are liberally distributed
throughout the movie,
if anybody's interested.
And you want to go see it
this weekend, don't you?
-Yeah, opening weekend.
-Before all your friends...
-Before anybody
ruins it for you.
-Yes. Yes.
And you want to see it
on the big screen.
-You do.
And, now, one thing that --
You all look the same,
but obviously technology
has changed a great deal.
This was an incredibly
technologically advanced film
in 1993.
More CGI now. Still some
animatronic stuff, yes?
-You know, originally,
I've been --
I've come to realize recently
it was a game-changing
technological intersection
with our movie in bringing
those dinosaurs to life.
Dennis Muren was, you know --
What was it called? ILM and CGI.
And -- And so --
And people have said
it's like when sound
was introduced into movies.
I never realized that,
but I guess over the last
couple of decades,
it really has changed things.
Now, in this movie,
Colin Trevorrow,
our wonderful director,
had a vision and an idea
that mostly
they would be not tennis balls
and painted in later
that we were looking at,
but animatronics.
-Wow!
-So it's a whole array
and a bigger array
of dinosaurs actually made,
that were there with us,
than you've ever seen.
That's what we mostly
did it with this time.
-You -- Obviously you have been
in the kind of films
where there will be merchandise
with your face on it,
but I have heard.
and you brought some examples,
that you're most excited
when people have actually
received a Jeff Goldblum tattoo.
-Well, I get excited
here and there, yeah.
-I mean -- And I guess
they've gone out of their way
to show you.
If they're gonna get it,
they're gonna show you.
-Sometimes that's true.
-There you go.
There's "Life Finds a Way."
There you are
coming out of an egg.
This --
I mean, that's really great.
-Hey. Some of these artists...
-They're really good.
This is -- I like --
Just this request is a fun one.
-I've never seen that one.
Me as the spitter.
-Yeah.
-I can get a little bit juicy
sometimes. That's true.
-But this -- I mean, the iconic
"Jurassic Park" sex symbol
right there.
Yeah, yeah, I love that.
Well, you enjoy it.
You enjoy it. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-You're also doing, uh --
You're reprising your role
as Grandmaster in "Thor,"
which is such a fun part,
and I'm very happy
you're doing that again.
-Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm looking forward to it.
-Well, thank you.
The -- I, uh -- This has --
You brought it up.
So it hasn't been publicly --
Seth, let me say this.
-Are you not?
Have we not publicly said
you're in it?
-[ Stammers ]
Let me say this.
-Okay.
-I think it's my greatest
theatrical appearance.
You -- You never
physically see me on screen.
-Wow.
-You don't hear an utterance
that I ever make.
And I'm never referred to
by any other character
in the movie.
But in many, many scenes,
the sensitive viewer
will feel my vibrations
all throughout.
-That's great.
-I could only have attempted
this this year --
I don't think before.
-Wow. That's great. Well, based
on what you said about it,
I'm happy to announce
I'm in it, too?
[ Laughter ]
Hey. Thank you for being here.
Oh. You're gonna stick around.
We're gonna keep you here.
You guys, that's Jeff Goldblum.
"Jurassic World: Dominion" is
in theaters and IMAX tomorrow.
We'll be right back
with D'Arcy Carden, everybody.